[Applaudissements]
ce soir je vais vous emmener en voyage
avec moi je vous en ai un endroit qui
est lointain
qui est très vaste
peut-être un peu sombre
je vais vous emmener dans l'espace
et vous inquiétez pas il y aura pas
besoin d'acheter un ticket qui coûte un
million de dollars on va juste y être
imaginez vous qu'on est dans l'espace et
qu'on regarde vers le bas vers notre
planète et j'espère que vous allez
apprécier la beauté de la vue qui se
présentent à vous et qui est juste et
peut-être ça vous ça ne vous surprend
pas un fait de voir la terre comme ça
les piles espace parce que vous êtes
habitué à ce genre de vue mais figurez
vous ça fait 40
50 ans que les satellites en orbite en
dessous nos têtes et qui prend des
images de la terre
je vous dis pas ça uniquement pour être
nostalgique où la question esthétique si
ça nous plaît ou pas mais aussi parce
que bas ceci est le sujet qui me
passionne en fait non je fais ma
recherche qui est d'observer la terre à
devoir les processus
environnementaux qui s'y passe donc vous
êtes en train de regarder cette image
depuis déjà quelques quelques secondes
vous aurez commencé à vous imaginer les
mastères les nuages vous avez vu
l'afrique vous voyez la végétation ça ça
joue avec le désert et tout ça c'est des
choses qu'on peut étudier maintenant
qu'on a ce genre à l'image satellite on
appelle ça de la télédétection spatiale
et j'y passe mes journées
ok c'est pas tous les jours en fait que
je prends tout le globe et je regarde la
terre de sion en fait moi mon quotidien
il se passe beaucoup plus près de nous à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de la
surface ou des satellites qu'on appelle
d'être résolution nous permettent
d'avoir des images qui ressemble à ça
donc la plupart des gens dans la salle
sans valaisan je suis sûr que vous avez
été à sion est de nouveau une image
comme ça j'imagine que ça ne vous
surprend de nouveau pas surtout ces
dernières années on a tous l'habitude
d'en voir tous les jours à chaque fois
que on est un endroit et on veut un
attendre un autre comme dans cet exemple
ici que vous voyez bas on a envie
d'aller se baigner au lac bah on va
prendre un téléphone portable on va
rentrer la donnaient sourire les îles et
nos téléphones portables est très gentil
et il va nous donner en fait le plus
court chemin donc le chemin qui nous
permet d arriver au plus vite
il ya bien une image là dessus et ça ça
nous permet de nous orienter mais en
fait notre fidèle compagnon numérique
n'utilise pas du tout l'image pour
trouver le fumant tout ce qu'il lui faut
c'est de savoir où elles heureuses
routier là où il ya un petit peu de
trafic
selon lui le signal qu'on a d'autres
téléphones portables donc en fait
l'image d'un tout ça dans votre très
cher google maps est totalement
cosmétique
mais en fait des nouveaux jeux refait le
même exemple qu'avant ça fait un petit
moment que vous regardez ces images dès
les mois et je suis sûr que chacun
d'entre vous la voix d'une manière
différente parce que chacun d'entre vous
a une expérience différente des besoins
différents et des intérêts différents
donc je vous invite à prendre quelques
secondes à penser à qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez savoir en regardant cette image
que vous n'avez pas besoin de répondre
mais pendant que vous réfléchissez je
vais juste vous donner deux trois
exemples en typiquement peut-être
quelqu'un dans la salle veut s'installer
dans la région pour commencer une
activité disons agricole il veut
s'installer pourra pour cultiver de la
vigne bats pour cela on pourrait
utiliser l'image pour savoir l'insolent
aimons vous pour savoir où en sachant
les pentes on pourrait savoir à quels
endroits sont le plus et moi approprié
pour initier ce genre d'activité est
peut-être la région qui est maintenant
affichée pour être une région
intéressante
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait s'installer
en ville de sion avec sa famille et
serait plutôt intéressé à savoir quels
sont les meilleurs endroits pour
s'installer et pour cela on doit savoir
où se trouvent les écoles peut-être
qu'on a des enfants savoir où sont les
espaces verts où il ya des arbres où il
fait bon vivre en ville et aussi bas on
aimerait bien être loin de des sources
de bruit comme l'aéroport ou peut-être
l'autoroute n'attendez pas trop vite et
à côté de tout
une autre personne pour être soucieuse
de l'environnement donc cette personne
pourrait vouloir savoir est ce que c'est
vrai que les températures continuent
d'augmenter et est ce que vraiment en
ville ça va de moins en moins bien par
rapport à la chaleur donc pour cela on
pourrait utiliser les images et essayer
de voir là où il ya des surfaces
imperméables donc qu'ils vont émettre
beaucoup de chaleur par la réflexion du
soleil ou et de voir quelle autre région
qui ont couvert végétal vont
contrecarrer cet effet nous donner de la
fraîcheur et en plus de ça on pourrait
voir essayer de voir ça dans le temps et
donc essayer de voir si vraiment ces
ventes aux trente dernières années il
fait de plus en plus chaud dans la
région
enfin dernier exemple un prix en continu
une quatrième personne pourrait être un
peu soucieuse un peu inquiète parce
qu'on voit beaucoup dans les nouvelles
tous ces inondations et les dangers que
de 2,2 où on habitait cette maison va
être inondé et donc pour cela pourrait
vouloir regarder dans les images quelles
zones très dangereuses par rapport à une
potentielle
inondations de la rivière donc de
nouveau on aurait besoin d'avoir accès à
la pente des zones construites qui
permettrait le ruissellement et avec
tout ça on sait un jour capable d'avoir
une image mentale qui nous dirait hockey
ici plus de danger ici - ici pas du tout
ok 4 personnes 4 profils complètement
différent quatre questions différentes
mais un dénominateur commun on peut
utiliser de l'imagerie pour répondre à
toutes ces questions
donc le besoin est là ce qui nous manque
c'est les moyens d arrivée
et parce qu'il reste quand même une
sorte de lanceurs d'une sorte de verrous
technologiques entre nous personne et
ses réponses à nos questions et c'est le
fait que pour avoir accès à cette
information doit passer par quelque
chose qui est très très technique donc
il doit passer par de la programmation
par l'informatique est bon en fait c'est
pas toujours facile de naviguer là
dedans et surtout si on n'a pas la
formation pour est ce que ça ne serait
pas plus facile d'avoir quelque chose
qui ressemble à ça enfin oui je sais
c'est juste un cahier mais est ce que ce
serait pas plus facile d'avoir quelque
chose ou on pourrait simplement écrire
notre question est derrière la machine
d'une manière que je chante on va parler
dans les prochaines minutes seraient
capables de nous donner la réponse dont
on a besoin
donc vous voyez il ya besoin de faire
communiquer demande qui eux ne se
parlent pas tous temps d'un côté on a le
monde des questions le monde des mots ou
comme nous on l'appelle le langage
naturel ok donc c'est un monde où nous
on sait ce qu'on veut en selle écrire
très bien de l'autre côté on a les
images on à la formation qu'on cherche à
extraire et il nous manque cette
connexion entre les deux et cette
connexion damas recherche de mon
quotidien se fait avec ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage machine
certains l'appellent intelligence
artificielle
saint-picq du big data ça a été
mentionné tout à l'heure et
l'apprentissage machine est ce qui va me
permettre de faire ce lien alors je sais
qui est pas tout le monde à la salle aa
connais ça donc je me suis permis de
graff de préparer un petit vidéo grâce à
un ami collaborateurs sur comment ça
marche et je vais vous montrer juste
deux minutes pour qu'on soit sur la même
page donc à moins d apprentissage
machine ce qui va essayer de faire il va
regarder ces images et va essayer de
donner la réponse correcte par rapport à
ce qu'il voit
et vous comprenez c'est un petit robot
c'est un petit irene qui a au début ne
sait absolument rien des pôles du
problème qu'il est en train de
considérer alors il va essayer de nous
dire qu'est ce qu'ils voient et au début
il sera terrible ils ne peuvent qu il ne
s'est pas du tout à quoi un animal
ressemble mais à chaque fois qu'il fait
une erreur on va le changer un tout
petit peu de manière à ce qu'ils aient
ils deviennent de plus en plus capables
de reconnaître ce qu'on cherche et après
on va faire ça pendant des heures des
heures et peut-être même des jours et dû
montrer des millions et des millions
d'exemple et à chaque fois qu'il se
trompe on va le changer à chaque fois
qu'il qui fait bien on ne fait rien et à
la fin de ce processus
la grume devient capable de reconnaître
ce qui va voir dans les images
c'est très très différent de ce qu'on
fait quand on étudie à l'école à la fin
on regarde un exemple quand on sait pas
on répète et on essaie d'apprendre
ok peut-être ça paraît un peu un peu
compliqué un peu sorcier mais var sous
revue c'est quelque chose que vous
utilisez tous les jours chacun d'entre
vous à moins si vous n'utilisez pas un
ordinateur et si vous n'avez pas un
téléphone portable dans la poche
j'imagine qu'il ya pas beaucoup de gens
dans la salle dans ce cas mais à chaque
fois qu'ils vous prenez une photo avec
votre smartphone à chaque fois que vous
traduisez un document d'un nouveau
logiciel préfet traduction si vous
conduisez une tesla si vous cherchez
quelque chose dans un navigateur à
chaque fois vous utilisez des ago in de
ce type des programmes de ce type
c'est juste que c'est pas être très
explicite et ça c'est ce qu'on cherche à
près de 6 c'est une sorte de solution ou
vous n'avez pas à vous soucier de
comment ça se passe mais ça se passe
bien
ok revenons à notre problème dé répondre
aux questions et un gros ça fait ça fait
maintenant trois ans quand il travaille
donc tant qu'on a retourné la question
un peu dans tous les sens et c'est ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a trouvé maintenant
pour l'instant c'est un système donc on
a cette boîte dont on parlait avant où
on écrit la question un texte en
français en anglais et après on a notre
petite algorithmes petit robot que cette
fois il est bleu et lui il va essayer en
fait de trouver une réponse parmi une
série de réponses possibles donc vous
voyez ça peut être oui non 2-3
matin après midi bonjour savez toutes
les réponses que potentiel pour qu'on
aimerait bien choisi mais maintenant
uniquement avec la question on n'est pas
capable de trouver la réponse il nous
faut aussi l'image mais comme l'image
est différent du texte en cdm au cd
photos bas on a besoin d'un autre ivory
pas notre petit robot qui fait à peu
près la même chose mais lui il est
spécialisé à comprendre des images et un
semblent ils vont travailler pour que
l'on puisse trouver la bonne réponse
parmi ces réponses possibles
alors on a mis cela à l'épreuve avec une
série d'image couvent la ville de new
york donc pour couvrir un centre de new
york il faut à peu près onze mille
images que vous avez trois exemples là
mais imaginez-vous aux mines donc sauf
grosse grosse pile d'image et pour
chacune de ces images on a généré 5
questions potentiel avec leurs réponses
qui nous intéresse donc en images sans
question ça nous fait plus d'un million
d'exemplaires ferrand alors quand vous
voyez la taille de la tâche c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas faire à
la main enfin moi que vous ayez beaucoup
de temps pas forcément le plein donc
avec un million d'exemple on a besoin de
passer par une approche comme celle là
et ça ne s'apprend en fait à
l'algorithme pour apprendre à peu près
sept jours donc on parle de 160 heures
donc lui il va continuer à regarder
question image réponse est ce que je
fais juste wind on retourne à l'arrière
et après ses sept jours donc
souvenez-vous qu'il part de zéro il n'a
aucune idée de nos questions ni des
images le début bah il arrive à répondre
à peu près 80% des fois correctement
bord je pense que c'est c'est
remarquable et surtout le fait c'est
quand il fait faux il donne qu'un ami
réponse logique il se passe pratiquement
jamais qui ont une question qui est
combien bla bla bla et nous répond oui
donc quand on me demande combien il a
tendance à répondre à un chiffre donc ça
c'est bien
enfin ça que pour nous pour nous c'est
logique mais pour un ordinateur mois
et voilà bah je voulais vous montrer de
trois résultats ici où on demandait la
taille des bâtiments de la surface bâtie
donc ils répondent bien donc dans la
première il y en a pas deuxième bière
100 mètres carrés il arrive à
reconnaître un lieu de culte donc il
doit comprendre en fait qu'est la petite
forme ronde sur le bas à droite c'est la
tour d'un minaret donc un moyen d
exemple petit à petit il y arrive mais
bien sûr je vous ai dit 80% et donc ça
veut dire que les faïences plantes
et quand ça arrive pas wallaby ghana il
ya des bâtiments laon le modèle ne les
voit pas tant pis des fois il donne
quand même des réponses qui pourrait
être logique donc là il dit qu' un
bâtiment en effet en avait trois à vous
d'en décider
mais bon tout ça et vous montrer un
exemple de quelque chose qu'on peut
faire à cette interface entre l'image
prise des satellites et notre monde qui
est fait de mots et moi ce que
j'aimerais attendre à terme ce serait un
système en fait tout quand on a une
image devant nous bat on peut poser une
question ça c'est moi quelques cheveux
blancs il y a quelques cheveux blancs et
j'aimerais que qu'il ya un ordinateur
qui est à côté ils sachent mieux fondre
à fait on est en train de regarder le
campus de l'epfl très bien mais
j'aimerais en même temps ce même
programme
qu'ils sachent me répondre à des
questions différentes qui impliquerait
du comptage je pourrais lui demander
combien de bâtiments je vois saurais me
dire 23 donc comprendre que ma question
est différente et qui doit me donner un
autre type de réponse est ensuite bah
pourquoi pas aussi lui permettre de
naviguer non seulement dans l'espace
aidé à mes questions mais aussi dans le
temps donc lui demandez pas lesquelles
de ces bâtiments sont récentes
comprendrait que c'est une question sur
le temps ils iraient en arrière une
quinzaine d'années en arrière comparer
les images et ils sont même répondre
quels bâtiments ont été construits entre
deux
hoquets l'exemple des bâtiments peut
paraître un peu un peu banal mais c'est
c'est la question de comprendre en fait
comment l'espace organise et comment ils
changent dans le temps et ça c'est des
choses fondamentales points après
prendre ces développements techniques et
les amener
à haut niveau qu'il nous faut pour
comprendre les questions fondamentales
du changement climatique ou pour être
prêt à répondre aux défis qui viendront
avec avec les inondations et tout ça
et je ne vous dis pas uniquement ça pour
donner un message militant pour être
actionnés compare tous avec la terreur
des changements climatiques c'est aussi
parce que je sais
c'est nécessaire et il nous permet
permettre après tout aussi bas de
voyager dans des pays lointains et de
rêver la planète